[Music]
good morning John it's Thursday already
Jesus May 3rd
[Applause]
happy birthday dad there are a few
things I don't want to talk about last
video that I didn't get a chance to talk
about in one of them two of two of them
actually asked you with Neil Gaiman
first thing I'm front of me of a copy of
his most recent publication fragile
things which is a collection of
excellent short stories Katherine and I
have been reading them to each other at
night I wanted to share with you
something from his introduction and on
the subject of naming animals can I just
say how happy I was to learn that the
word Yeti literally translated
apparently means that thing over there
quick brave Himalayan guide what's that
thing over there Oh
Yeti I see second thing apparently they
might be giants is doing the soundtrack
to Cora Lee in the movie yes oh my god
that is so cool finding that out has
made Neil Gaiman way way cooler in my
book so now you know how much I like
there might be giants now on the things
that don't have to do with Neil Gaiman
Katherine is not researching marijuana
weed research like she's doing research
on weeds
Katherine is researching plant
communities and how to eliminate
invasive species like spotted knapweed
the job starts in a couple of weeks and
it's going to be really weird to not
have her around all the time and finally
about the Bermuda Triangle Lauren
Johnson is now banned book what the it's
not cool but what is cool is what
happened a brother a 2.0 I think that
your video yesterday has had more
comments than any other Brotherhood 2.0
video so apparently people came more
about book banning than they do about my
obsession with Helen Hunt which is
definitely a good thing thank you all so
much for standing up for the librarians
and for Maureen great work now I think I
may go out and buy the Bermuda Triangle
because I want to see what all of the
fuss is about and I think that's all so
John I will see you tomorrow